vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Buen día para usted Marta
Hola Ángela Buenos días era impensable
comenzar de otra manera Tenemos que
hablar de rusa después de un fin de
semana que estuvo intenso después de una
cortísima rebelión Armada contra el
gobierno de Vladimir Putin por parte del
grupo Wagner y por supuesto esta noticia
está en todos los medios vamos a empezar
si le parece con el que dice en
exclusiva que la causa penal contra
Jenny sigue en curso pues si Ángela una
información que sería un poco contraria
a ese supuesto pacto que habrían llegado
entre el gobierno de Putin y el grupo
Wagner bajo la mediación de Alexander
lucashenko por la cual Pues los cargos
contra
habrían retirado por presunta rebelión
lo que dice esta información del medio
comersant es que la investigación sigue
en curso recordemos que el servicio
Federal de seguridad de Rusia abrió una
investigación contra privoying el
viernes por incitar un motín armado tras
prome derrocar el liderazgo militar del
ejército regular ruso lo que dice
conversan es que es prematuro decir que
esta investigación penal de presunta de
rebelión ha quedado cerrada y que la
causa sigue adelante todo esto citando a
Fuentes cercanas a la investigación esta
información ya ha sido replicada por
agencias de información rusas entonces
queda en el aire saber si pregojin va a
ser o no condenado por rebelión y podría
enfrentar penas de prisión entre 12 y 20
años hasta ahora solo un general
retirado de la inteligencia rusa ha sido
condenada bajo este precepto de rebelión
y veremos si pregon es el segundo Pero
vamos a seguir Perdón Ángela con Diego
mozi que nos hace un análisis No que
titula cómo termina el viaje de Wagner a
la capital pregolín fue enviado a
belarus después de una puñalada por la
espalda eso dice Diego mozi el trabajo
del grupo militar también se va a
regular después de esta rebelión los
hechos se midieron como una prueba de
estrés para el gobierno de Vladimir
Putin y hubo cierre de filas en torno al
presidente ruso pri gojin tenía
simpatizantes entre las grandes urbes
rusas pero ahora dice Diego moscy
cualquier apoyo Es categóricamente
inaceptable sobre el futuro del grupo
Wagner citado un experto por el medio
dice se puede reformatear y mantener
pero con un liderazgo diferente los
nuevos reclutas tendrán que firmar un
contrato con el Ministerio de defensa
los ya reclutas tendrán que disolverse
entre el ejército regular y la guardia
nacional y el interrogante es qué pasa
con los militantes del grupo Wagner en
el exterior como Siria Libia u otros
países africanos Por otra parte hemos
destacado el consumo skaya Prada un
medio muy afín al kremlin que dice que
la exitosa mediación de Alex no fue tal
sino que fue un éxito atribuido al
presidente Vladimir Putin las
condiciones las había puesto Putin y
lucashenko se limitó a transmitir la
información a Jeff Jenny dice el consumo
skaia Prada que Putin podría haber
acabado con esta rebelión por la fuerza
pero eligió ser más efectivo y aquí una
declaración un poco controvertida de
este medio que dice textualmente tanto
con opositores políticos como con
oligarcas Putin prefiere tratar de
resolver los asuntos pacíficamente
apelando a la mente del oponente Putin
nunca elige soluciones Aparentemente
espectaculares sino que siempre se ubica
en las posiciones efectivas y sin
embargo todo esto está muy en el campo
de lo no confirmado es que es
impresionante porque Putin no es un
hombre que negocie o no es conocido al
menos por eso y si nos preguntamos qué
va a pasar con la guerra en Ucrania sin
la presencia del grupo Wagner Qué
sabemos ha sido primordial en este tema
ahora que los medios occidentales tienen
una visión mucho más comprometedora para
el presidente Ruso y dicen que su poder
simplemente está en jaque después de
esto que ha sido calificado por líderes
occidentales como una gran muestra de la
brecha que hay en Rusia Así es Ángel
habíamos destacado por empezar un
análisis del New York Times Que firma
antro antontrona yosky que titula podría
Putin perder el poder el presidente ruso
se ha definido a sí mismo siempre como
un garante de la estabilidad en Rusia
pero tras los hechos de este fin de
semana ahora están jaque esa afirmación
dice este análisis del New York Times
que lo que ha ocurrido en las últimas
horas es el desafío más dramático a la
autoridad de Vladimir Putin en sus 23
años de reinado citado un director de un
medio moscovita que tiene vínculos con
el kremlin dice que este fin de semana
se ha planteado una hipótesis que hasta
ahora era impensable Y es que personas
cercanas a Putin le estarían intentando
convencer de que el presidente no se
presente la elección en las elecciones
presidenciales de la próxima Primavera
Aunque dice este análisis del neor Times
que sería prematuro hablar de una caída
o una desaparición de Vladimir Putin de
la escena política rusa ya que Putin ha
dado muestras de que el sistema ruso se
ha mantenido firme pese a las sanciones
y a ese aislamiento tras la invasión a
Ucrania Por otra parte hemos destacado
una Tribuna del periódico el país que
fueron Que firma Jesús Núñez que dice
este no ha sido el último asalto del
pulso entre Putin y pregogen este bueno
el kremlin necesita a Wagner en el
frente o sea con prigo sin al frente o
con otra persona al frente de este grupo
paramilitar textualmente dice esta
Tribuna del país No solo necesita
pivochine en el campo de batalla sino
para sus innumerables misiones de guerra
sucia y desinformación masiva también
hay dudas sobre lo que puede hacer ahora
dice el país que que el presidente
haya negado aniquilar a todos los
Rebeldes solo es una muestra de que se
anuncian nuevas tormentas en el futuro y
por otra parte hemos destacado un
reportaje con civiles en kiev que hace
de Guardian que dicen que han estado
pegados al teléfono todo este fin de
semana tras las informaciones de la
inestabilidad en Rusia que en toda
Ucrania se vivió con alegría
paradójicamente que el grupo Wagner
estuviera liderando una rebelión contra
el kremlin y que según analistas también
hay temores de que un Putin herido pueda
convertirse en un botín más peligroso
pero es que ni un fin de semana duró
esto Marta En todo caso hay efectos
colaterales y por eso vamos a destacar
un análisis que hace el medio
independiente ruso del Times que afirma
que los expertos Ven fisuras a partir de
este episodio en la relación
Moscú Beijing si Ángela concretamente
dice el most you Times citando a
expertos que los últimos acontecimientos
podrían suponer arena en las ruedas en
la asociación estratégica sin límites
entre sí y Vladimir Putin china vería el
fracaso de Putin frente a pregojin como
un golpe de incompetencia y es una
muestra de la debilidad de Rusia frente
a su principal Aliado que es Rusia Rusia
Entonces se consolida como el socio
menor de esta estrategia de cooperación
y dice el most you Times citando
expertos china necesita una Rusia con la
que pueda ser un socio adecuado y para
ello tiene que ser fuerte Rusia no puede
estar hecha jirones no funciona pues
mire Marta Lamentablemente ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo nos queda por fuera
el tema de la reacción a los medios
después de las elecciones en Guatemala
la buena noticia es que el invitado del
día seguro nos va a poder ampliar sobre
ello Muchísimas gracias Marta gracias
Ángela